we'll now return to the questions that
we asked in the very beginning of this
lesson
starting from genomes how can we
transform them
into synteny blocks and
the first thing i want you to learn is
the notion of genomic dot plot
let's arrange genome along
x coordinate and along y-coordinate
and let's represent every k-mer
that is shared at position x and y in
the genome
as a dot at position with coordinates
x and y in this case i show you genomic
dot plot for
k-mer size equals three and it only
consists of the diagonal
in the genomic dot plot of course
diagonal
is always present in the genomic dot
plot because
card k-mers at the coordinate x and
x are always the same but here's a
genomic dot plot for k
equal 2 and you can see that in this
case the
number of dots increased as compared to
k
equals 3 for example these four dots
correspond to repeated occurrences
of the tumor ct in the gene
so far we talked about
a genome consisting of one strand but in
reality of course
genome consists of two strands and
therefore
we should take care of both identical
and reverse complementary k-mers while
representing genomic dot plots as shown
here
in this case red points correspond to
identical k-mers and blue points
correspond to reverse complementary
k-mers now
this is how genomic dot plot look like
when we compare
a genome against itself but can we also
construct genomic dot plots
when comparing two different genomes and
here's an
example of comparing one genome with
another one that is obtained from the
first one by a reversal
and in this case you can see that a
reversal
corresponds to -45 degree diagonal
formed by blue points
in this genomic dot plot now
from looking at the
small strength let's now construct
genomic dot plot
for entire e coli and salmonella
genomes and human eye
immediately see syntony blocks in this
genomic dot plot they simply correspond
to various diagonals
and we only pay attention to
sufficiently long diagonal because
small diagonal or small points clusters
of point may represent
noise in this case so we see
five synteny blocks five diagonal
corresponding
to a block marked as a b
c and d and e and if we project these
blocks
on x x-axis we will get an
arrangement of synteny blocks in e coli
and if we project them on y-axis then
we'll get
an arrangement of synteny blocks in
salmonella
and now we are ready to analyze the two
break distance
between these two genomes therefore
construction of synteny blocks
essentially amount
to constructing diagonals in the genomic
dot plot and here's finding synteny
blocks
problem input is a set of
points in genomic dot plots in 2d and
the output
is a set of diagonals in dot plot
representing synteny blocks does it make
sense
of course it doesn't make sense because
i have not defined
what diagonals are look at this genomic
dot plot and you can see that diagonals
are not perfect
because there are many insertion
deletions
mismatches and many other artifacts and
therefore
human eye has ability to somehow process
this genomic dot plot into five
diagonals but we really do not know what
our brain is doing
while making this transformation can we
come up
with an algorithm for constructing this
deck
let's try let's look at the
genomic dot plot between two different
genomes that we constructed before
and let's represent every dot
in the dot plot as a note in graph
and we will form edges in this graph
by simply connecting closely located
points for example points that are
allocated a distance
less than max distance where max
distance
is a parameter what will happen we will
connect
certain points by edges and
you can see from here that diagonals
actually correspond to connected
components in this graph
moreover we probably should ignore very
small connected companions
for example accompanied located in the
upper
right corner and low left corner
but the three remaining components
should
be accepted as synteny blocks in our
genome
and therefore i offer you
the following algorithm for solving the
problem
let's form a graph whose node set is the
set of points in dot plot
and connect two nodes by an edge if the
corresponding
nodes allocated at close difference from
another
the connected components in the
resulting graph defines antenna block
and afterwards delete small sentiment
blocks
of course this is not the only algorithm
that tries to model
what the human eye is doing while
clustering points in 2d and our brain is
very good at clustering
i can give you another algorithm for
example this one that i call
amalgamate and it actually different but
it looks like it's doing
almost the same thing first step define
each point in dot plot as a separate
block
and iteratively amalgamates the
resulting block
how do we amalgamate the blocks they
amalgamate two blocks and combine them
into a single block if they contain two
points
that are separated by small distance in
another genome
and as before delete small synteny
blocks
so we have a problem when we have two
algorithms for solving it which
algorithm would you use
instead of answering this question you
should ask me
what problem i actually want you to
solve
because i have never defined an
algorithmic problem
that i want you to solve you should have
refused
uh coming up with an algorithm before
actually seeing
the problem i want to address
unfortunately in bioinformatics it's not
as simple
i have been working on the problem of
synteny block generations
for 10 years now and i failed
to formulate this problem as a rigorous
algorithmic problem
and that's why we are mercy at all of
our intuition
and some people may like symphony
algorithm better other people may like
amalgamate algorithm better
how would we choose the choice is
should be done based on the practical
results
and if you implement this algorithm and
run them
then you see that synteny algorithm
gives a reasonable and biologically
adequate result
but amalgamate algorithm also it looks
reasonable it looks like it models
what human eye may be doing gives
completely
wrong results after developing the
algorithm for constructing
synteny blocks we are now ready to find
out
what are the synteny blocks between
human and mouse
x chromosome and here's the genomic dot
plot for the x chromosome
consisting of 25 000 dots
we form a synthetic graph
on this 25 000 nodes and in this
slide you can see the result in
connected components
we further process these connected
components and represent them
as perfect plus 45 degrees or
minus 45 degree diagonals in 2d
where are the 11 synteny blocks between
human and mouse
that we have been considering in this
lecture
well if you project this 11 blocks
in 2d to x-axis you will get the
arrangement
of human synteny blocks and if you
project it
to y-axis then you will get the
arrangement of mouse
synthetic blocks moreover since we are
not particularly interested in scale
of this block and even some if some
blocks appear small
there are maybe hundreds of generations
of the blocks it's just an
issue of scale so let's represent each
block
by the diagonal of the same size
and once again if we project this blocks
in 2d
to the x-axis we will get arrangement
of synteny blocks in philip and if we
project it to y-axis
we will get the arrangement of synteny
blocks in mouse
and now after we constructed synteny
blocks
for two genomes how about constructing
synteny blocks
for three genomes you can think about
generalizing our synteny block
construction approach to more than two
genomes but
what about constructing synteny blocks
for 100 genomes
that are being sequencing sequence now
this actually turns out to be a very
difficult problem
and nobody in the world today is able to
construct
synteny blocks for 100 genomes maybe
after this course
you will suggest a reasonable approach
for this but
interesting thing is that if we learn
how to construct synteny blocks for many
genomes
we will be able to come up with a very
accurate picture of chromosomal
organization
in our distant ancestor so there is
a lot of work ahead in developing genome
rearrangement and symphony block
construction algorithm
but this is already beyond the
scope of this course